Speaker 1: Rand Paul, the Republican senator
from Kentucky, is being absolutely ridiculed
for saying, Look, here is how Democrats are
stealing elections. And when you go and you read,
you see, Oh, Democrats are stealing elections by
convincing voters to vote for them and encouraging
voters to go out and vote or to vote absentee or
to determine how it is that they plan to vote.
It's amazing that he even thought this
was a logical thing to put out there. So
Rand Paul tweeted out two days ago a link to
an article in the American Conservative OK,
the article we're going to look at.
It's called the Wisconsin purchase,
and a lot of the article is about Mark Zuckerberg,
Facebook and the Center for Technology and Civil
Civic Life's involvement in Wisconsin. OK. And
Rand Paul tweeted out a quote from the article.
Adding how to steal an election. So Rand
Paul says how to steal an election quote,
ceding an area heavy with potential Democratic
votes with as many absentee ballots as possible,
targeting and convincing potential voters to
compete, complete them in a legally valid way and
then harvesting and counting the results. This
is called elections. This is called elections.
Look at what Rand Paul is saying. The way
that Democrats have used trickery to win
is figuring out where are there lots of Democrats
who might vote, but they might not going there,
convincing them to vote and having them fill
out absentee ballots in a legally valid way.
In other words, voting running an election, and
it really is worth looking at the actual article
that that is linked to. And there is stuff. If
you look at the article in sum total, you will
find a bunch of stuff here about the influence of
money electioneering Mark Zuckerberg grants using
using entities to shield one's personal and like.
There's a whole bunch of stuff in here that is
not the way I would like to see elections run, but
it is legal and it is part of the sort of status
quo campaign finance structure that Republicans,
generally speaking, are absolutely fine with.
But then the incredible part is you look at the
strategy. And it's called running an election,
so there's a heading called how the Wisconsin
five sought to implement the Wisconsin Safe
Voting Plan. And it says the Wisconsin Safe
Voting Plan lists four major strategic objectives.
First, encourage and increase absentee voting by
mail and early in-person, mainly through providing
assistance in completing absentee ballots and
submitting them and installing ballot drop boxes.
There's nothing ominous there. It's make sure
that people have places to drop off ballots. Make
sure people know how to fill out their ballots
completely legal. It's called voter engagement.
Second, dramatically expand strategic voter
education and outreach efforts, particularly
to historically disenfranchized residents. This
is their smoking gun where this is, the strategy
literally is do outreach, particularly to groups
that have been been historically disenfranchized
so that they know how to vote, where to
vote, what their options are for voting,
how to get absentee ballots? Wow. How dark
and ominous third recruit election workers,
mainly from appeared young activists who would
replace the usual older Election Day volunteers
get young people involved. Typically, these
Election Day volunteers are older. That's a
reality. Get young people involved. Completely
legal, completely good and a distant fourth
in emphasis and level of funding was fund COVID 19
safety related COVID 19 related safety measures.
Nothing remotely concerning there. Just
nothing remotely concern concerning there.
They also in the article, put in italics as if
this is the smoking gun. And this is the part that
Rand Paul tweeted out. But all of the resources
developed toward ballot curing drop boxes, vote
navigators, Partizan activists infiltrating local
election office, etc. were aimed at one ultimate
end. Here's their big smoking gun, as Rand Paul
tweeted seating an area heavy with potential
Democratic votes with as many absentee ballots
as possible, targeting and convincing potential
voters to complete them in a legally valid
way. Then harvesting and counting the results.
This is what we call voting. This is what
we call running an election. And per Rand
Paul's explanation. Here is Stacey Abrams, who
is also listed in this article, explaining how
to quote steal the election. And by that, I mean,
working to win the hearts and minds of voters
so that they vote for you. Here is Stacey Abrams.
Speaker 2: Now you have long been a major voting
rights advocate, but we are seeing a lot of new
laws restricting voting not just in Georgia but
across the country. So how are you going to
tackle this and keep up this fight in 2022?
I'm excited to know that when the Senate comes
back into session in January, the US Senate is
going to take up the Freedom to Vote Act and
the John Lewis Voting Rights Advancement Act.
These are two critical laws that will help
protect voting rights across the country
because it's not about partizanship. This is about
patriotism. My issue is it who gets to vote. It's
that everyone who is eligible is allowed
to vote. My job as a candidate, of course,
is to convince them to vote for me. But my job as
an American is to ensure that every eligible voter
has the right and the ability to cast a ballot.
Speaker 1: So the important takeaway here
is that for the Republican Party, this
hasn't been the strategy for a decade.
They are presenting as some kind of concerning or
disturbing strategy, making sure people have the
wherewithal and resources to vote, encouraging
them to do so and targeting areas where there's
lots of potential voters for your side that's
called running an election. Republicans haven't
done that for at least a decade. They essentially
gave up trying to convince voters on policy in
2012 with Mitt Romney. You still had it a little
bit when Mitt Romney ran against Barack Obama.
They still sort of were running on policy,
although the policy was increasingly vague and
amorphous. In 2016, it was completely abandoned.
Policy was completely abandoned. Trump still
said things that sounded like policy, but it
was not actually policy. The 2018 midterm, then
Republicans just straight up abandoned policy.
In 2020, running on policy was a distant memory,
and there's no indication that in 2022,
Republicans are going to run on the policy.
They're going to run on trying to make it
difficult to vote. And this is what they've been
doing, make it difficult to vote, particularly
for people that are not likely to vote for you
and run on cultural issues, critical race
theory, etc. You guys know the roster. So
we have actually seen Democrats try to run on
a platform of policy and voter enfranchisement.
I'm not saying it's a platform I love in all ways.
I've had no shortage of critiques and criticisms
of the Democratic platform, but it's been
let's try to get people to want to vote.
And let's use policy rather than cultural issues
to do that. And Republicans running on cultural
issues, running on fear, if you don't vote for
us, brown people are going to invade from the
southern border. We're going to take away what
was it? Trump said. They would. You would they
would give you toilets that you have to flush
10 to 15 times and take away indoor heating and
cooling. And all these different things will
protect you. We'll protect the suburbs, right?
Extremely racially coded language will protect
you from people taking your jobs and, you know,
raping and all these different things. So now when
you actually just run normal elections, it ends up
being presented as this is how they are trying
to steal the election. This is called running an
election. This is called politics and just another
completely humiliating public statement by Senator
Rand Paul. We'll have it. We'll have that tweet
of his and more coverage of this on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show. You
can also follow me on Instagram at David Pakman.